we forcibly use the white girls we used
to put crack in their cigarettes whoa
I told you [__] I told you yo I told you
hey yo I told you shall I hit play oh
yes you shall
we we uh we used to run trains on white
girls
it's okay I'm just running the trains
not the worst thing in the world if a
girl want to have a choo-choo train rain
on her often times they don't want to
I'm not saying that it's always the case
but oftentimes when you run a train they
are being set up that's a problem with
true true is I didn't buy the tickets
for all those passengers huh yo they
they go to the apartment there's one
dude there oh yeah that's just my roomie
whatever whatnot then they getting it on
and then next thing you know
door opens and four fine [__] come in
the train thing yes funny thing to joke
about and stuff like that but the
reality is most of them girls don't want
that oh we used to do it uh without
permission so it's not like she came
over and said hey I want to sleep with
all you guys yeah we say hey man that
white girl like you get over here and
then we uh put oh [__] and then we uh oh
[__]
oh my God and you realize first if you
were like oh [__] oh wait uh he already
said it I guess if you're not gonna stop
him oh [__] because even they realize
this is a [__] weird thing to say
yeah yeah we just come in with dicks out
oh [__] yeah yeah she's about to go
into it
a dude literally just got on camera and
pretty much admit it she didn't want it
we just showed up with digs out and
things happened now some of you might be
like why did she fight or whatever
imagine a bigger bunch of dudes and you
and you trap that's why they lured
they're there that's the thing it's like
if you guys want to get involved with
her do this that's fine just tell her
beforehand see if she wants to do it no
you wait till she's there where she's
surrounded by dudes who are bigger and
stronger than her and then you you pop
it on her okay well when the police come
for you actually you say it was
consensual you won't get any of my
sympathy they can throw your ass in jail
because you're not only out yourself
snitching but you doing [__] that's
[__] disgusting
I'm mentally abusive and I do some
psychological abuse
I'm a man that's strong to believe that
some women need their ass whooping they
put too so I so I advocate Rich too for
some people
whoa I told you [__] I told you yo I
told you
hey yo I told you hey
hey
yo
this is the type of person these red
pills like to hang out I have to say nah
be oh yeah
hey yo hold on homie you gotta think
about it we're kids right we're kids
yeah yeah because not only there's a
different era uh yeah that was that was
back down unfortunately
a lot of you people out there really
consider your software Bill your
community will never be taken seriously
and if you guys
because you're big you red pill is
holding people accountable
right you want a whole woman accountable
if you got those people in your ranks
and you do not hold them accountable and
you invite them on your podcast to get
clicks and Views and this and that what
not
your movement will never be taken
seriously you cannot
like not understand like these people
are calling us misogynistic and not
understand why I mean you got dudes
literally advocating for violence
against women I'm fine I'm fine with you
being red pill do your thing and I
understand there's certain people that
are Red Bull and this and that they
don't think like that the minute these
guys are associated with you and the
minute you got these clowns inviting
them to and just not saying nothing like
whoa okay not holding them accountable
like the whole women accountable all the
time like people getting up just not
saying anything just getting off and
leave and getting you know get the [__]
out of here and this and that and
whenever dude like that on you don't say
[__] if you don't hold them accountable
we won't take you seriously ever from
outside
my guys that's the reason why I don't
look good automatically people are gonna
pin that on you Hey listen listen
they're not about holding people
accountable they're about holding women
accountable even when they get mad at
dudes it's dudes who are simping who are
by proxy boosting up women so it's
always about women it's only about
holding women accountable if they don't
have this kind of energy for dudes when
they're being this kind of pathetic or
criminal no it is only exclusively for
women the red pill was actually a bit
like the feminism movement what I was
trying to say is that your MO is almost
the same and identical it's just that
they have different views about each
other whenever you have a feminist that
is saying that she's she's advocating
for equality and then there's all these
things that happening to men and she's
not saying [__] you're like
you're not holding all these women
accountable when they see some wild [__]
you're shutting the [__] up you're not
saying nothing you turn your back you
turn your eye you pretend like it's not
happening that's you
when this [__] happened and you don't
say [__] that's you people are gonna pin
you with that listen I'm not gonna say
this whole record thing I think that's
an individual this dude just admitted to
crying not just crying raping women
beating them up and thinking that shit's
kosher and you got to think man social
media is some kind of drug where people
can't shut they [__] mouths about
what they do and I'm glad he's
self-centered but like good Lord
Bobby what was that line from uh Ms Doom
there's something about uh rappers being
the courtroom in their own court cases
being their own star Witness
that's really what it is I'm not even
gonna say stop self snitching because
I'm glad this dude snitched on himself
but
in other circumstances if you're doing
things that are maybe criminal but not
morally reprehensible stop stop
snitching but if it's morally
reprehensible tell on yourself because
we want you off these [__] streets
so you get your [__] ass out of
here if you got a problem with what I
say I believe I don't believe women
shouldn't be beat I think it's okay to
whoop up you can't tell no man what
forcibly ran train we forcibly used to
white girls and we used to sneak crack
in the white girl's cigarettes to [__]
them we didn't sneak nothing and they
drank you lying on me we didn't do the
black girl like that only white girl
white boy they get mad now
I'm kidding man
Jesus Christ call it what it is
that's racism
no no but black people shut the [__] up
that right there you're about to
experience Enigma so listen
it was one time we was going to go get
this white girl it was me Michael
Montoya my [__] bone you throwing all
their names not only
[Music]
oh my God
yo
God damn [__] in another name Cedric
and right now I would have said you give
a [__] named Jason Jason Anderson
what up what a filthy disgusting
what a filthy disgusting human being and
you realize like a lot of these dudes
associate with each other it's like it's
weird to me how you constantly see folks
who are a little bit sus hang around
other people who are even more sus and
then it's all a coincidence the Matrix
The Matrix The Matrix no [__] that's
you that's you and your friends that's
the people that you choose to associate
with God damn and it'll be fine if you
want to have a shitty person on the on
the pot or whatever but I was like you
gotta push back when they openly
admitted to this stuff you gotta push
back you invite this person it's like
there's an elephant in the room and you
want to talk about this nigga's Little
Pink Dress what no this dude a whole ass
rapist you know we want to always talk
about the false accusing it falls yeah
okay sure they do exist but then y'all
also associate would do to do the
graping who are proud about it who
advocate for it it's like oh
where's the balance that's what I'm
asking where's the balance everybody
want to talk about one side they never
want to say like hey man you know what
I'm not even saying things got to be
even but good Lord the [__]
you're interviewing do you even know
about this guy no I don't know who that
guy is I have no clue that guy I've just
seen him on someone Charleston white
apparently is his name I think
Charleston white is the founder and CEO
of helping young people Excel an
organization dedicated to educating
teens and helping steer them away from
future crime the group has even worked
directly with members of One at Texas
largest Hispanic gangs you know what
actually just dawned on me what remember
that clip we played from that podcast
and Waka Flocka flip yeah if something
just dawned on me in watching this video
a dragon to show it's about if you're
gonna make a statement back it up the
raping thing was wrong that like I just
said what was it correct you were
basically saying like a woman should
just say no right then and there and
leave not all girls can do that though
okay but that's what they should do that
doesn't that's what they should do but
not all girls are able to follow that
whose fault is that yeah I'm guessing
right whose fault is that maybe it's a
dude who tried to get her massively
drunk maybe he's the guy who invited her
over for a one-on-one and then ambushed
her with seven other [__] maybe it's
the dude who's been looking for a woman
who's emotionally and mentally
vulnerable and then manipulating her and
coercing her and gaslighting her and
beating her into submission you know
what I mean like agency isn't always on
the other person you can't render
someone so [__] depending on you that
you [__] them up or like we say all
the time men and women are different
women are built physically less strong
to think they can always assert their
boundaries in every circumstances when
you just literally had a wrist on your
podcast who you did not push back on for
any of the [__] that he did I don't know
somebody just speaking a little bit
funny you want to get loud and proud
with these women tell them it's their
fault and this that but when you had a
Grapist on your [__] podcast a
self-admitted proud one you had no smoke
ain't you the one who says oh we should
get normalized telling people when they
say dumb [__] like we got to go back to
telling people they're stupid we need to
go back to bullying people letting them
know no that's not really how the world
works you sound dumb change your my way
of thinking but we don't bully people no
more and tell them they're dumb we need
to go back to doing that where's that
energy for him you didn't say nothing
what this man came on and said he did
one of the most despicable things a
human being could possibly do zero
pushback you were basically saying like
a woman should just say no right then
and there and leave not all girls can do
that though okay but that's what they
should do that doesn't that's what they
should do but not all girls are able to
follow that whose fault is that yeah I'm
guessing us women right
[Laughter]
you're saying responsibility but like we
said these men are two-faced they are
going to put on a front who picked the
man
who picked the men no they're lying
about who they are who picked them in
he's like [__] you want everybody to
have a lie detector sometimes you get
duped by somebody no there's somebody
who thinks sometimes you think you're
going on a one-on-one date you show up
and it's seven other [__] they're
never gonna say they're never gonna say
anything about that no no it's like
every part of the discourse and what you
said earlier was really facts about this
being the other side of feminism the way
same way like feminists will just be
blind I'll believe all women
just I might just leave
um I don't know I don't feel comfortable
when it comes down to the whole
conversation and where you guys stand up
all right bye all right all right
two more minutes how you feel versus
what's real or two different things all
right
culture is a myth culture is a myth you
you literally had a Grapist on and you
didn't say a [__] word to him
I don't know I'm gonna call it grape
culture I don't like that term either
but it do seem like you're protecting
your own just saying when they talk
about how these men protect each other
that's not like you
because when he came on and said he did
that [__] where was your pushback ux law
enforcement but you sitting here cozying
up with grapists okay
okay I keep forgetting about that [__]
yeah he's a whole fed sitting here
beside a grapes proudly and this man
runs look the the Charleston white dude
runs a program for the Youth yeah crazy
bro [__] is wild out here it really is
some of the worst people on the planet
leading young men but hey anyways
anything else I told you I I listen I
played two seconds of the clip and I
need to watch this and preach I didn't
know what was going to do yeah but this
[__] is
I didn't know what this [__] gonna be
son of a whole ass I actually want you
guys think in the comments below